okay let's talk now going from Trump's
completely failed outreach to black
people to Trump's completely failed
outreach to Hispanic people I'm going to
play a clip for you of joy Reid from
MSNBC talking to Marco Gutierrez the
founder of the group Latinos for Trump
now we could talk a little bit about the
absurdity of a group called Latinos for
Trump unfortunately I don't have ten
hours today we only have an hour for the
show so I'm gonna focus on the acute
insanity of this clip where mr.
Gutierrez was asked what is the risk of
Latino Hispanic culture becoming more
prevalent in the United States it's not
crime it's not rape as Donald Trump
might suggest it's not drugs or
criminality it's tacos ladies and
gentlemen take a listen to this my
culture is a very dominant culture and
it's imposing and it's causing problems
if you don't do something about it
you're gonna have taco trucks every
corner wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute I'm sorry hold on a second I
have to let audronado in here I don't
even know what that means and I'm almost
afraid to ask Mexico these we are a
culture that we are have a lot of peace
that we're being to the United States
but we also have problems and you guys
are going nuts over something that
there's a tenth step to this problem you
guys already talking about the tenth
step we haven't even started walking
this path have you seen the devastating
effects of a chicken taco with both
cilantro and onions and hot sauce on it
it is destructive surprise this Latinos
for Trump founder is a real estate
scammer look up his name Marco Gutierrez
scam real estate you'll see there's
numerous claims against him grievances
from the state of California I'm just
shocked Jason that both trumps black and
Latino surrogates are lying scammers of
different kinds it fits perfectly with
the Trump campaign this is their new new
campaign slogan there's gonna be taco
trucks in every corner what do you have
to live
I was looking at a tweet from a Benjamin
Applebaum from the New York Times and
I'll put up what he tweeted here for
people to take a look at today we
learned there are two Americas one that
thinks taco trucks on every corner is
terrifying and one that thinks delicious
there will never be a more powerful
meaning to Taco Tuesday then Tuesday
November 8th of 2016 that is really when
Taco Tuesday will take on a new meaning
and I was thinking about the tragedy
here you know first came the Chinese
American restaurants with chop suey in
the early 1900s and Americans were too
afraid to speak out because they liked
the food then came the Italian
restaurants in Boston and New York City
in the 1920s and 30s and Americans
remain silent because they serve
delicious food and then in the 70s the
French bistros continuing into the 1980s
and nobody said a word because it turned
out that escargot and croque monsieur
are absolutely fantastic and then
Hillary Clinton was elected in came the
taco trucks and there was no one left to
speak up anymore because Mexicans are
some of the best cooks in the best
restaurants all over the United States
and we all went to the taco trucks to
support honest entrepreneurs offering
great food at reasonable prices it is
the tragedy Jason of the American
culinary history I don't know how else
to say it yeah it's it's a terrible
debacle I don't know what we're gonna do
we're just gonna get more al Pastore
burritos yeah and some some late-night
enchiladas so imposing I mean really
just horrible horrible that this this
delicious food in convenient places is
being imposed on all of us as Americans
okay
I've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly Millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is Zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your zip
each CarShare member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars
sign up at join Zipcar comm slash David